okay reporters are all set for your
press conference - big moment are you
excited now oh are you worried about
your voice cracking want me to help you
warm up your throat no that entail I'll
just show you don't show me tell me I
blow hot air in my hands I stroke your
neck that's not gonna happen it's now I
am stressed I think Holt got into my
head you might have to delay the press
conference it's the moment we've been
waiting for my dad's driving home early
from his brother's funeral to watch it
live she's doing what if you want me to
put it in a better context I can't this
was very important to him Holt is a
great cop
and I know the demotions driving him
crazy but his gut is usually right if we
need to find that hotdog cart guy okay
fine
but who do we know that could find us a
random New York hotdog guy
[Music]
so you need a little help from the
wiener warriors well I hate that just
tell us what you know please there's
Lou's dogs he started about real play
Big Mike's just to dud for banks Frank's
great mustard selection think he's vegan
I'd rather eat Charlie doesn't he'll
dent a dog it's got a really nice at you
Johnny Arkansas sure is a Little Rock
style although he can serve at Razorback
style okay enough enough we don't have
time for this
just tell us who has a card at sixth and
eleventh oh you know hot dog carts there
what never no way not a chance
zoning issue forget about it Jake its
hunger town oh my god Holt was right if
I die will you look after my cat I'm
really more of a dog person looks like
we got ourselves a standoff first secure
great okay thanks for saving us Peralta
thank Debbie we tracked you using her
pedometer oh my goodness I helped and I
got four new foot friend requests what a
day guys hey so today was pretty intense
Jimmy caching the shooter I know that's
a great story I just hope it can get in
good enough shape to play me in the
movie you know hmm
yeah um also something else happened I
thought I might be pregnant
really yeah I'm not I got my period and
I took a pregnancy test but it didn't
work because I drank 11 gallons of water
told you water is bad for you it's not
the takeaway you're absolutely right how
are you how do you feel you okay I mean
I was really stressed this wasn't our
plan and we agreed we'd wait a year and
there's so much to do first and it would
have been crazy right yeah it would have
been but also might have been kind of
cool honestly I was secretly bummed when
the tests came back negative
should we just start trying seriously
yeah seriously
okay yeah oh wait it's after 11:00 my
interview Swiss me on the news
an incredible conclusion to a terrifying
day and we were able to get a comment
from the men who helped solve this case
they call us the Weiner warriors
you